rebonjour federica bonjour j'ai mis
bonjour à toutes et à tous en ce 11
novembre en ce lundi 11 novembre notre
invité philippe pierre charles bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté cette invitation
oui bonjour à tous et à toutes merci de
m'avoir invité
vous êtes là ce matin en tant que l'un
des porte parole du grs un parti donc
martiniquais d'idéologie plutôt
trotskiste internationaliste alors le
groupe révolution socialiste qui a eu
pour habitude lors des années
précédentes 1 de prendre part aux
élections municipales de philippe
pierre-charles avec plus ou moins de
succès selon les scrutins vous n'avez
jamais eu de candidat élu maire
peut-être aussi si oui on joue pas
bouillon âge voilà il ya déjà longtemps
effectivement effectivement monsieur
jean elie c'est ça il était à l'époque
au groupe révolution sociale voilà il a
été maire il avait même été conseiller
général effectivement changer de vie
voilà il a changé depuis
donc voila mais c'est vrai que ça
remonte aux années 80 90 c'était le
siècle dernier
c'était ça en tout cas philippe pierre
charles est ce que pour 2020 le groupe
révolution socialiste est ce que donc le
grs vous allez remettre ça vous allez
présenter des listes ou des candidats
sur des listes pour les prochaines
élections municipales déjà brillant nous
permettent même vu mais aussi les hôtes
pour le team musique nous et là j'étais
dans mon élément
musicalement et socialement ces titres
est très agréable et présentement aussi
de 2,10 à ti paroles en l'air
un événement qui caneo les jolies ya des
billets en coup d'état sanglant qui l'a
fait en bolivie qui va verser evo
morales et le président le président de
la région au niveau i des banques
populaires légitimes n'ont pas raté non
loin du cap à l'union européenne a
rapidement condamné toute qualité
à tête de l'homme bataille allait sa
maladie que le groupe évolue services et
solidaire du peuple bolivienne à cette
épreuve difficile l'amérique latine
l'amérique du sud elle bouge beaucoup à
ce moment et nous appelons les uns et
les autres à exprimer cette solidarité à
ne pas laisser ce peuple voilà seul face
à ses agresseurs mais ça vient
contrecarrer un petit peu l'annoncé de
la libération de lula au brésil mais
mais mais revenons à ces élections
municipales en martinique si vous voulez
bien philippe pierre charles
donc je vous demandais si le grs va
prendre part aux élections l'année
prochaine
d'accord je vais vous dire la vérité
comme d'habitude nous n'avons pas fait
une discussion sérieuse approfondie
systématiques sur ce sujet jusqu'à
maintenant pourquoi parce qu'un bon ben
moi dans les combats nous dans la lutte
pour nous la politique s'est posée et
chercher à résoudre les problèmes de la
population des problèmes de santé les
problèmes d'emploi les problèmes de
pouvoir d'achat les problèmes
d'environnement
c'est ça la politique et si ça ne sert
pas cela d'un bon ça ne sert qu'à des
carrières de politiciens ce n'est pas
notre préoccupation c'est pour ça que
par exemple un séjour aussi bon si vous
voulez bien aujourd'hui
alors on va y venir on va y venir mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que souvent on
avait l'impression que vous n'êtes pas
le seul parti d'autres partis en
martinique
justement des fois profitent de ces
campagnes électorales pour en faire des
tribunes pour justement davantage
popularisé pour faire infuser leur leurs
luttes et leurs idées à l'ambition que
ses organes vous voyez pas ce côté de la
liste de la lutte des postes si vous
voulez dans en mairie voilà ça peut être
bon mais pour nous il faut qu'ils aient
que
une des choses soit le prolongement de
l'autre un combat électoral n'a de sens
que si il est la poursuite de la lutte
sur un plan des institutions et que si
il permet d'aider à résoudre le problème
voilà cela n'est pas salé par pas ce
bien là qu'on résout il si vous voulez
je compris alors que de ce point de vue
là pour eux je dirais la société
martiniquaise pour le peuple
martiniquais justement quel est l'enjeu
principal à vos yeux de ses prochaines
élections municipales que vous y preniez
part d'une manière ou d'une autre ou pas
c'est quoi l'enjeu là au moment où on
parle un jeu pour nous serait de
répondre aux préoccupations actuelles
des personnes des gens qui soient des
provocations extrêmement sérieuse oui
nous sommes et pour lesquels les
municipalités les élus municipaux
doivent s'engager je suppose selon vous
les municipalités pourraient être un
pôle de résistance la pole de lutte
contre tous les méfaits d'une politique
d'un gouvernement
aujourd'hui nous sommes attaqués sur les
retraites on est attaqué sur les
indemnités de chômage on est attaqué sur
les services publics qui sont chine
pompe tonne et bon comment comment
croire
si vous voulez un maire qui nous dit il
va s'occuper de la santé qui va se
répéter de l'école qui va s'occuper du
bien-être des gens qui va s'occuper de
leur santé etc
6e merlas ne s'implique pas dans le
combat pour sortir de cette fac à bonal
rue du clos du côté des pesticides
s'il ne le fait pas aujourd'hui qui va
crois qu'il va le faire demain quand il
sera élu
bon ça n'est pas ce n'est pas une
position penser que dans parmi le
personnel politique et notamment parmi
les maires en martinique qu'il y en a
suffisamment qui a une prise de
conscience et qu'il y en a suffisamment
qui s'impliquent justement dans ce type
d'action de sauvegarde pour principe des
remises aux concerts je suis ces
attaques
bon en a beaucoup qui savent bien de
quoi il s'agit je ne peux pas dire non
plus que aucun maire ne fait pas fausse
vous même titre au titre du du collectif
du liant nage pour dépolluer la
martinique vous avez fait êtes allez
donc commune nous avait été accueilli
par des mères qui ça c'est le visionnage
qui a fait une douzaine de réunions
publiques des mers bon c'est bien mais
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin
ce gouvernement qui est là il ne va pas
mettre les moyens à la disposition de la
solution de ségovie va pas faire ci a
pas un puissant mouvement en face de lui
bon sur des questions aussi importantes
que les sargasses et et chlordécone
entre autres je ne parle même pas de la
santé du sein nu de la santé des
hôpitaux et c'est bon les moyens qui
sont mis sont dérisoires et ils ne
sortent des moyens que s'il ya vraiment
une pression populaire beaucoup de gens
nous disent gbagbo voilà c'est le front
populaire qui a mis les congés payés en
france et donc en martinique les valeurs
populaires cepal
le gouvernement l'a fait d'accord mais
c'est parce qu'il ya eu 15 jours de
grève après l'élection
c'est sa gamme be l'écho gp on bénéficie
des congés pays dans ce pays à martinez
grâce à cette lutte qui a lieu en 1936
on nous dit que ouais l'abolition de
l'esclavagé c'est vrai que c'est un
maire qui a signé le premier arrêté
l'abolition pourrit pas puis à cette
pièce et le méga signé et puis c'est le
gouverneur qui a confirmé le lendemain
bon mais qui est arraché les choses
c'est la lutte des esclaves celle-ci
version c'est le 22 bnc ça alors
philippe hier soir le membre du grs
groupe révolution socialiste ont encore
quelques mots sur les municipales alors
vous n'êtes pas encore décidé un pour
savoir si vous allez présenter des
candidats ou pas ou si vous allez
participer à des listes mais
habituellement aux grs vous portiez
l'effort au cours des élections
municipales sur fort de france en
particulier
oui c'est vrai vous présentez des
silencieux de toute façon nous allons
dire non mais parler fort de france
comme c'est comme si quand même la ville
la plus importante de ce lille là dessus
voilà il n'est pas exclu qu'on soit dans
une semaine je veux dire que là
aujourd'hui
les combats aux gens c'est pour empêcher
que l'on écrase la population davantage
dans des politiques c'est les lacs qui
sont menées en france et qui sont de
plus en plus combattu il ya un appel à
une grève générale comme en cent le 5
décembre face bon ça va faire du bruit
je vous relayez volleyant martinique cet
aveu discute nous avons enfin bord
classé au niveau syndical mon niveau
syndical est même en tant que parti oui
d'accord un thonier poussant soutien en
soutien et en soutien le meeting qui est
fait jeudi qui vient à la maison des
syndicats par la cdmt avec d'ailleurs
représentants des mouvements
progressistes en france de copernic qui
va bon peut parler sur le mouvement
syndical les gilet jaune la grève du 5
décembre le rôle des femmes dans ces
mobilisations bon tout ça sera l'hôte du
jour bon nous soutenons ça tout à fait
ça va être moyen de commencer à discuter
de cette perspective entendu innovest de
trois minutes maximum philippe pierre
charles alors on sait que quelque part
en arrière-plan de ces élections
municipales qui ne sont pas que
municipal d'ailleurs un élections
municipales et communautaires parce
qu'elles serviront aussi à désigner les
nouveaux élus au sein des communautés
d'agglomération les trois communautés
d'agglo en martinique donc élections
municipales certes mais derrière
deuxième coup communautaire et puis
territoriales juste un an après et on
sait que donc ça se prépare déjà tous à
l'automne il ya des alliances qui
commence ça peut-être se trame et enfin
il ya des discussions ici ou là alors
est-ce que vous en êtes au grs qu'est-ce
que vous participez de cela de ces
manoeuvres pour ainsi dire entre
guillemets entre partis politiques pour
constituer des alliances en vue des
élections à l'essai a trait à l'accès
il souhaite que ne pas nous allier à des
gens qui s'allie à la doite parce que
nous ne voulons pas être des petits
alliés indirects des colonialistes bon
mais il est certain aussi que pour cette
élection territoriale n'allons pas
rester muet et inactifs nous allons
prendre une position puisqu'à conforme
aux intérêts des masses populaires
ce sera peut-être notre trop polis ou ce
sera un indice peut-être anecdotes
bombay donc ça peut pas exclure ça ça ne
vous est pas inconnu absolument pas de
même que soit pas exclu que nous
présentions voilà mais vous entends
c'est une union des candidats aux
élections municipales qui viennent c'est
évident donc voilà donc vous entendez
être présent aussi pour les prochaines
élections territoriales on a un peu un
peu le temps après il ya les municipales
avant l'an prochain pour terminer alors
le gérer ce à prix avait déjà quand même
et estaing comme dirait jean parti qui
avait déjà une cause féministe enfin
qu'ils adhéraient à la cause féministe
qui a beaucoup fait de l'action et de
lutte de de ce point de vue en
martinique
et puis
le virage écologiste aussi vous vous
l'avez pris alors du coup et on termine
là dessus puisque c'est l'actualité
d'aujourd'hui vous organisé un séminaire
aujourd'hui achète cher enfin vous le
grs quoi philippe pierre-charles sur le
thème lutte et débats féministe et
écologique
oui tout à fait ce sont deux questions
conclut la mémoire conclut et là dessus
extrêmement important que c'est
d'ailleurs peut-être de ce début du
21ème siècle les deux terrains sur
lesquels les choses ont le plus bouger
la réflexion a le plus avancé
ce n'est pas un hasard parce que c'est
une réponse à une situation une réponse
une situation du capitalisme mondialisé
qui aggrave les problèmes
d'environnement et les problèmes des
écosystèmes c'est vraiment une menace
qui pèse sur l'humanité elle même et qui
en même temps aggrave les inégalités de
manière terrible et les principales
victimes des inégalités c'est vrai que
ce sont les femmes dont les femmes du
peuple les femmes travailleuses les
femmes privés d'emploi bon donc ces deux
thèmes importants sur lesquels il ya 6
ou à nouveau de la pensée progressiste
et nous voulons parler avec des
camarades qui s'y connaissent et qui
sont impliqués dans le combat d'accord
vous fait ça toute la journée donc à
chaque chaire ont conclu nous concluons
aujourd'hui merci au fil des pierres
charles donc d'avoir vous est adressé
aux auditrices et auditeurs de martine
que la première ce matin boulin de vie
bon séminaire merci à vous et base je
voulais à tout le monde
[Musique]